hello everyone welcome to today's
presentation and thank you for joining
my name is james caffrey
i'm the director of strategic marketing
for genomics here at kyogen
the title of my talk today is
accelerating genomic surveillance of
sars cove 2 with high throughput next
generation sequencing
we've been able to do that with this new
next generation sequencing product the
kaya seek direct sars cove 2 kit which
significantly accelerates and simplifies
the workflow for amplifying enriching
and sequencing the whole viral genome
this kit is designed specifically for
short read sequencers from illumina and
it has a number of other positive
features that are a consequence of those
workflow improvements like requiring
much less plastic wear
compared with most existing arctic based
sars cov2 sequencing workflows and i'll
describe those and other features of
this kit a little bit later
the overall solution i will cover also
includes a new data analysis and variant
calling service that allows rapid scale
up of informatics capability without
your lab having to invest in i.t
infrastructure or additional
bioinformatics expertise
these data analysis and variant calling
steps are also rate limiting for many
labs at the moment so we've built upon
our core kaijan digital insights
bioinformatics platform to address that
need as well
so before i begin uh let me just
highlight that
these kyogen products that i will talk
about today are intended for molecular
biology applications these products are
not intended for the diagnosis
prevention or treatment of a disease
and for up-to-date licensing information
and product specific disclaimers please
see the respective kaijen kit handbook
or user manual
kaijinkit handbooks and user manuals are
available at www.kaijan.com
or can be requested from kaijan
technical services or from your local
distributor
so here's how i've broken out the talk
today i'd like to start with an overview
of where we stand in terms particularly
focused on sequencing of the of the
genome where we stand with respect to
the pandemic
and focus on how
kaijin has high has
responded to those needs um then i'll
take uh some time to describe this new
direct sars cove2 kit that we've just
launched and talk about the workflow
improvements i mentioned
i'll then cover some data regarding that
kit where we compare the performance of
this new kit with our existing arctic
based sars cove 2 sequencing solution
and finally i'll wrap up with
a brief overview of the new service that
i was mentioning for data analysis and
variant interpretation
using uh called our kaijenkov2 insights
service
so i want to start by noting that kaijan
like many of our peer com companies
has a full spectrum of responses to the
pandemic
that includes both research products
which are highlighted here some of which
are highlighted here
as well as diagnostic testing of patient
samples we have a variety of solutions
on the market for that
and other products over here on the
right hand side
that are also grayed out which focus on
host pathogen interactions
these studies are particularly important
for
vaccine development and the development
of therapeutics
the kit that i'm going to talk about
today the new direct source cove 2
sequencing kit uh falls squarely into
this area for genomic epidemiology and
surveillance um
and so i'm gonna focus on on this
section here targeted viral whole genome
sequencing that's where this kit sits so
for the rest of the talk what i'll do is
compare this new kit with uh with our
existing solution and how we've made
improvements to the overall workflow
now the motivation for doing this is is
probably very understandable to every
one of you who are in the public health
labs
around the world
or indeed any other research labs that
are working on sars co2 sequencing
obviously a number of
variants of concern have emerged
around the world in the last number of
months and indeed they've not just
emerged they've become dominant in uh
and fixed in various populations and
regions around the world
a couple of them are shown here the b117
variant or lineage which first emerged
in the united kingdom and has spread
worldwide is now the dominant lineage
here in the united states as well
b1 351
emerged in south africa um it's
suspected to
have an impact on the efficacy of some
vaccines that are already out there
and new mutations continued and variants
continue to emerge for example the p1
and the p2
variants that have
sort of come out in brazil
as well as other regional variants that
that continue to show up
so there's an ongoing evolution of the
virus of course and
that means that there has been a
massive increase in demand for
sequencing the virus to help understand
which mutations are actually circulating
in a population
and
to identify new mutations that may
emerge that could potentially become
variants of concern
now what that has done
from a
consequence perspective among other
things is it has created a very large
pressure again on supply chains for
example for labs around the world
for
not just now for testing reagents as
happened at the very beginning of the
pandemic
around this time last year
but now for
products that are needed for research as
well so we see for example
that materials like pipette tips
plastics plates and other kinds of
materials are in short supply for many
labs
and so combined with the need to do
massive sequencing scale up
we've realized that there was a need to
look at the workflow that currently
exists for sequencing the sars coffee
virus
and see what we could do to improve
both the
speed shortening the workflow um
increasing the the throughput and
ideally
reducing the need for lab consumables
now just to focus on the variance for a
moment um and i'm going to highlight
b117 and b351 here uh just to kind of
give a little bit of additional context
what you can see
is that
each of these lineages as they're called
includes mutations that span across the
entire viral genome um everybody focuses
a lot of people focus on spike
protein for for good reason but you can
see that these mutations occur um in
other open reading frames across the
genome as well
and the mutations are a variety of types
this is the list of
non-synonymous mutations
that occur in the b117 on the left-hand
side here and in this table the b351
lineage um in the middle of the slide
and you can see that most of these
mutations are point mutations at the
nucleotide level which lead to amino
acid changes in the respective protein
but in addition to that there are also
deletions as you can see here in the
spike gene for b1 and 7 where there's a
deletion at this position that removes a
single amino acid and actually a double
deletion here side-by-side removal of of
two amino acids in this case so these
mutations are particularly well studied
in spike
because those mutations are
suspected to and in some cases actually
have been demonstrated to show
increased viral transmissibility
and or pathogenicity and in fact in the
case of b117 some of these mutations
have indeed been shown to be able to be
both more transmissible as well as uh
more pathogenic than the ancestral
strains that have been circulating in
the first part of 2020
and not only that there's a kind of a
third factor that is is really relevant
now
and that is the ability of some of these
mutations to potentially evade immune
response that's particularly important
at this point given the
the development of vaccines and the
rollout of vaccines
so there's a lot of concern around the
emergence of
potentially new mutations that will um
allow the virus to evade uh vaccine
surveillance and vaccine uh immune
response from people
and because of all of that um really
when you want to do genomic surveillance
uh really the money the only
cost-effective way of doing this in a
high-throughput manner is obviously to
new to use next-generation sequencing
with
a reasonably high throughput in terms of
the number of samples that you can cover
so kyogen has actually had a
solution for sequencing the viral genome
out since early 2020 and that solution
is based it's on the right hand side of
this slide
and it's called the kaisek sars cove 2
primer panel now this
combination of of kits that we have a
primer panel as well as a library prep
ngs library preparation
kit called the kaiseka fx dna library
kit this combination of those two kits
allows for the
amplification and enrichment of
of the entire viral genome using the
arctic based approach and the arctic
based approach that i've referred to
here is comes from the arctic network a
sort of a public effort um and that team
has been involved in the past in in many
um outbreaks particularly ebola and
others that have occurred and
very quickly after the development of
the of the stars cove ii um pandemic
last year the arctic team developed a
series of protocols and primers
to enrich for the virus so that you
could sequence the whole viral genome
and uh kaijan
built um this
kyasic sars koftu primer panel based on
that arctic approach um which was
originally developed uh particularly for
compatibility with long read sequencers
like those from oxford nanopore so the
amplicons that are used to amplify the
virus in the case of the arctic approach
are about 400 base pairs long they are
overlapping so that you get redund
redundancy across the entire genome and
they give very high levels of
of sequence coverage and uniformity and
and we see that with um with uh with our
primer panel as well
they also in the case uh that we have
when you pair our primer panel with our
kaiseek fx dna library kit um you have
the ability to
uh to to multiplex samples up to 384
using
the unique dual indices that come along
with this fx dna library kit
now having said that we have seen and
we've heard from our customers um that
there are some challenges with uh with
this workflow even though it gives very
very high performance i'll show you some
of that performance data in a few slides
a little bit later in the presentation
um but
one of the challenges that a lot of labs
face with this workflow is that because
the amplicons are 400 base pairs in size
they require fragmentation if you want
to run those fragments and sequence them
on short read sequencers
it's also a workflow that involves
ligation steps in our case
with a number of beat cleanups and
quantification steps and so what we have
found is that in practice
executing this workflow for a reasonable
number of samples can can easily take a
day and a half
or or more
and
as we looked at the growing need for
speed and scale up and throughput
we realized that we needed to look again
at this workflow and see how we might be
able to optimize it in the entire kit
and optimize it and that's where
the new kit that i'm talking about today
the kaiseek direct source cove 2 kit
comes from
right this is a kit that
is a it's a single box solution for
doing both viral amplification
as well as
live ngs library preparation so it's
it's just one kit in particular we've
been able to reduce the
workflow down to about a four hour um
four or four and a half hour library
prep
workflow it requires
fewer steps dramatically less hands-on
time and fewer steps there's no
fragmentation fragmentation or ligation
involved
and that has actually allowed us to drop
the amount of plastic where needed for
this kit compared to
our arctic solution over here
and it still provides extremely highly
uniform in fact even better more highly
uniform coverage of the genome
than than even with our primer panel and
i'll show you in the next few slides uh
some of that data
a key component of this kit is that it
uses
shorter amplicons
250 base pairs or so in size so
that's why no fragmentation is needed
so if you go now to just talking a
little bit more about this kit and about
the workflow itself let's just go into
that in a little bit more detail
um
and as this as this slide sort of
alludes to here um you know the the
sequence the race uh against the virus
you know every minute counts um we can
certainly see that in
some of the very uh challenging news
that is coming out of various uh regions
around the world at the moment
um so to to kind of reiterate the three
most important things to say about this
kit
it includes a simpler workflow which
reduces the overall time
the workflow time
by about half when we compare it with
the arctic based approaches
it has shorter fragments shorter
amplicons and overlapping
amplicons in two pools of primers so it
doesn't require fragmentation we've been
able to remove the ligation steps by
doing pcr directed
indexing um by in other words adding
unique
dual indices to these amplicons using
pcr rather than ligation
and because of that
and i'll show this in a little bit more
detail in a moment
less plastic wear required step by step
um the coverage that we see with this uh
kit is is just as good and in many cases
quite significantly better than what we
see with our with our current
arctic-based workflow both at the
uniformity level in terms of gene
specific and um across the entire viral
genome in coverage
it's designed for high throughput
sequencing on illumina instruments so
these unique dual indices are
particularly
designed for use on alumina sequencers
and these overlapping
primer pools
are obviously designed much more for
short read sequencing
we have launched the product already
just recently with
unique dual indus index sets that allow
multiplexing up to 384 samples at a time
and we are just about to add to that
list a whole other set of udis that will
ultimately allow you to multiplex up to
768 samples on one
sequencing run now obviously that number
of samples requires a novaseq and the
right kind of flow cell
and that additional set of udis is
coming shortly
so here's the comparison if you will
side by side of the current arctic
workflow on the bottom of the screen
here
um with the
the new shorter workflow for the sars
for the direct source cove2 kit and as
you can see with the arctic base
workflow there are
these first steps here are done with our
primer panel and then with our kaiseek
fx dna library kit to actually generate
the libraries that can be sequenced on
the sequencer i should point out that
our primer panel is also compatible with
other library prep kits from from other
vendors so you're not just um
restricted to using a kaijen kit here
for the for the ngs library prep
this workflow uh as we said uh earlier
takes uh 10 to 16 hours or so
um you know hands up not all hands on of
course but elapsed time uh when you've
got a reasonable number of samples what
we've been able to do is remove a number
of steps in that workflow and you can
see that here for the direct kit in the
upper part of the slide so you go from
viral rna sample
through cdna synthesis
direct enrichment of the viral genome
there's a beat cleanup in the middle
a quantification normalization step here
then you library
index and amplify another beam cleanup
and then your libraries are ready to go
onto the sequencer and in our hands
we can process 96 samples using manual
methods actually using multi-channel
pipetter for example in four to five
hours
we are also
recognizing that this is a streamlined
workflow that has a greater option for
automation
and we're actively working on a number
of automation scripts to automate this
on some
robotic liquid handlers there'll be more
information of that coming from kaiju
shortly
so removing these workflow challenges
it's it's a simpler uh workflow less
hands-on time
and as i said the workflow supports
automation uh or it will um shortly when
we provide some automation scripts
you can use any high-quality rna isolate
for your sample input
there's no need to dilute that rna or to
pre-qualify it um no need to do any
reverse transcription hydro primer
hybridization
we've got overlapping as i said and uh
um redundant uh primer design um pools
that uh create these 250 base pair
amplicons um it's a fixed number of
cycles regardless of the copy number of
the virus going into your front end of
this workflow
single cleanup sample here at this point
this protocol is designed to work with
plates so it can be done with
multi-channel pipettors
in reasonably high throughput as well
and then
on quantification and normalization
we're actually looking at the moment at
whether we can remove this step as well
to to
accelerate the workflow even further
and any updates that will be published
in in updated versions of our kit
handbook um when they come out
uh then you add the indexes
um and library amplification
and again a single cleanup per sample at
the end uh with this protocol obviously
as i said designed to work with plates
now let me just move to some uh some
data on the performance of this kit so
this slide shows um in the upper two
traces
um the library yield that we get from
the kaisek direct source cove 2 kit
and in the lower two traces
examples of library yield that we get
from our arctic based uh primer panel
approach
and what you can see in the primer panel
down here just to start there is you can
see that there's a so-called sort of a
hump and a peak
for uh whether you're doing a hundred
copies or a thousand copies input into
this library
preparation and that hump and peak uh
represents the fact that you've got
amplicons that are about 450 400 base
pairs in size uh with some extra tags on
either end that then have to get
fragmented in order for them to be run
effectively on a short read sequencer
and so the hump that you see here is the
fact that it's representative of the
fact that that fragmentation does not
necessarily always go to completion now
even though you've got a hump and a peak
we find that we and our customers find
that they still get excellent genomic
coverage both from a coverage
perspective and a uniformity perspective
with our primer panel
when you run the same kind of analysis
with our direct kit what you can see is
a trace that's much more similar to what
people expect to see from a library
yield um a much tighter peak uh again
depending irrespective of the number of
copies going in at the front end and i
would just draw your attention to the
fact that um the scale on the x-axis
here for sorry on the y-axis for the
upper traces is is significantly higher
than for the lower ones so you also get
a much higher yield of library using the
direct source cove2 kit
now when we look at
um
performance uh from a
uniformity and a coverage perspective
we find that with our with our um
arctic base primer panel approach uh
which is shown in the red bars here
we get
excellent coverage at one x of the mean
um almost ninety percent
uh at uh one x of the mean that does
drop a bit when you when you you know re
plot these data as 0.2 x of the mean
what we see with our direct kit which is
shown in blue the two blue bars here is
that we're getting 99 plus percent
coverage at 0.1 x of the mean um and uh
in the mid 90s for 0.2 x of the mean um
so we see an increased level of
uniformity
with our direct kit compared to even
with our arctic primer panel and when we
look at base level coverage
depth at different depths you can see
that again for the um
for the
arctic based primer panel in red
we've got pretty good um coverage base
level coverage at 20x sequencing depth
almost 99 but that does drop down to
about 95.96
at 100x coverage we see no such drop
equivalent drop for the
uh for the direct kit
so uh all in all um we think uh these
performance numbers uh and these are i
should point out are done with with um
with with atcc positive controls um
uh we see excellent performance and even
better performance with the direct kit
even compared with our already good
arctic-based approach
what does that coverage look like from a
gene specific perspective so these three
traces here uh just
dig into the s gene the n gene and the
endo-riponuclease gene and the red
trace is is the
coverage um uniformity for the
kaisiksarskov2 primer panel in other
words the arctic approach the blue trace
is the coverage for our new direct kit
and what you can see with the arctic
approach is that again these longer
amplicons
you can see that there are areas it's
already pretty good coverage 1000 x
but
there are definitely areas of peak and
trough in this um red trace
whereas the the direct kit provides a
much more uniform
um
coverage across the length of the spike
gene here um with yeah with the direct
kit there are some areas of higher and
lower but it's generally much more
uniform than what we see with uh with
our arctic approach same thing is true
for the for the n gene um and likewise
for the endo ripo nuclease gene and and
this is particularly um worth pointing
out that for endorphins gene uh we did
see early on that there were regions of
this gene that sort of dropped out and
even with our arctic approach we had to
um add additional primers across this
region and rebalance the concentrations
of some of the primers to get this level
of coverage that you see in the red
trace um again when you look at that
equivalent approach uh with the direct
kit the new direct kit in blue you see
just a much more uniform level of
coverage and indeed higher levels of
coverage
now um this is the graph is an attempt
to in a static format to show what that
coverage looks like across the entire
genome so we're looking at here from
base one to base uh almost thirty
thousand of the entire source code two
viral genome um and again what you can
see in red the arctic base of our arctic
based approach in blue our direct kit
approach um there's more um jaggedness
to these uh traces of course because
we're looking at you know at an entire
viral genome in one slide um but i think
it's pretty obvious that uh the um to
just even by eye that both the coverage
is higher with our direct kit in blue uh
compared to our um our arctic based
approach um and the uniformity is is
broader the only two regions i would
point out where we don't have good
coverage are right at the very five
prime end of the genome the first 50 or
60 bases or so and right at the very
three prime end of the genome and that's
true given the fact that um this is a
amplicon-based tiling approach to to
amplify this virus and there's just no
other way of getting those regions with
that kind of approach
okay i'm going to wrap up uh with uh
just some short words on our on our data
analysis and variant uh calling solution
from our digital insights team here um
they have launched we have launched a
new kaijun cove to insights service um
and this basically is um
a a serve a managed service that we
provide to labs where
we will essentially take uh um
fast q files from uh that have been
generated off a sequencer um analyze
them at scale in the cloud provide a
report an example of which it uh is
shown here on the right-hand side of the
slide with a variety of pieces of
information which i'll go into in a bit
more detail now um and then hand you
back that report and so you can sort of
scale your analysis of data
through the web essentially without
having to invest in i.t infrastructure
or indeed additional bioinformatics
expertise or resources
this service supports most of the source
code to sequencing panel options that
are out there and those are not just
kaya seek ones um the primer panel and
the direct kit but others as well
it's fast and accurate and secure so
wherever you are in the world um this is
a solution that you can use scalably um
no in need for infrastructure and expert
resources it's fully automated and we
provide lots of quality control steps
it's easy to integrate the results you
get back from us with existing uh your
existing research i.t infrastructure
and so on and um the data that we send
back uh is um is capable of being
analyzed in in our workhorse uh data
analysis solution for ngs the kaijan clc
genomics workbench
and uh we have a pricing model here
based on on sample usage
so here's what that report looks like
you can tag it to your own you can brand
it and logo it for your own lab if you
want
it provides a lot of qc metrics
very visibly around the quality of your
run and the data the data analysis uh is
performed the workflow name and version
number and so on are um are provided and
then uh the report also includes
information about the reference
sequences that were used for the
workflow
lineage predictions by pangolin and
clade predictions from nexclade
and of course most importantly probably
at the moment coverage and variant
profiles for the for the genes that are
covered divided into consensus variants
and lower frequency variants in a table
at the bottom of the report
this is what the textual perspective
your lab is here you provide fast q
files we do all of the work in the cloud
send you back outputs that you can then
incorporate into your own
lims system or other research i.t
infrastructure that you have you can
look a lot of this data in the clc
genomics workbench and for each sample a
number of different types of reports are
provided
so with that let me summarize and just
come back now to the kit for a moment
and say for our
kai seek direct soros cove 2 kit it
comes in two sample sizes two kit sizes
uh 96 samples and 384 samples for the 96
sample configurations we have at launch
now four kits they are um they follow
the same kind of common nomenclature for
indic indexed kits uh kits a b c and d
each of these has 96
udis in them and they can all be mixed
together to get to 384 multiplexing in
one go
and
as i said earlier we're going to be
launching another set of udis this will
be kits sets e through h and they can
also be
multiplexed with the 8 through d kits
and so you now have the ability to scale
up to 768 samples at a time
and with that um i would like to thank
you for your attention today uh if you
have any questions about this
please contact us at kaya webinars at
kaijan.com
thanks again for your attention i i hope
you have found this useful and have a
great rest of your day
you